[Music]
as vladimir putin's war in ukraine
grinds on
[Music]
new worries are emerging on the global
stage
every day the war lasts world food
supplies are
damaged could affect hundreds of
millions of the world's most vulnerable
people and all across the world
from a looming global food crisis
to nato and beyond
how is this war changing the world
we have our cardi on the line where are
you
i'm on the road actually on the approach
is to keep if i turn my phone you will
be able to see this is the just uh the
key is in the distance and here's the
tank traps last week you you visited
odessa and um you you
this this just yesterday i think
president zielenski appealed for
countries to break the blockade of
odessa to allow merchant ships through
could you just give a give a sense of
why odessa is so important is is um the
most important port in ukraine uh 90
of uh ukrainian exports grain
uh mostly uh and metal was going either
through a dslr through mariupol but the
biggest problem is this is is now how to
get it out of the country i've just seen
some farmers i've seen their grain uh
barns being destroyed by russian bombing
extraordinary i mean one large farm
where two uh bombs were dropped by by a
russian plane the farmers are continuing
to sow they are going to have a good
harvest they say
they started the way i just been uh they
came back to to farming about a month
ago when the russians have finally left
that area of chattanooga and what they
are getting now the first harvest is
actually russian shells
they're collecting there's a lot of
debris there's a lot of unexploded
russian
mines and shells in the fields and the
farmers are working around them they're
saying we can have a harvest how we get
it out of the country is our biggest
problem
the consequences of ukraine being shut
off from global export markets
potentially ukraine's harvest being
dramatically affected will have
fairly calamitous consequences on what
is already a looming global food crisis
my sense is that this is going to become
a bigger and bigger part of the sort of
global conversation about ukraine in the
coming months but ed what's your sense
of that
well i think the first thing to to think
about is how important uh russia and
ukraine are to
to the food system countries about 800
million people depend upon them for a
large share of their uh if their imports
so for instance about 80 percent um of
egypt's grain comes from
ukraine uh and russia and that 100
million people in egypt there are 90
million people in congo and about 70
percent of their grain comes from
ukraine and russia so these are these
are very large numbers so the dependency
is clearly there
and then um i think the war hits the
supply in three ways it hits it directly
because
uh grain and oils sunflower oil is a
very important
crop in both those countries those are
exported
and those exports are being blocked
either because there's a blockade
against ukrainian ports or because
russian
shipping can't get insurance because it
may be in danger so there's a big
shortage of supply
but there are two other ways in which um
the the supply of
food will be affected one is um in
fertilizers russia is a really important
source
of the three main kinds of fertilizer uh
and so that countries that do plant
um will will find that yields will go
down because they won't be able to
afford to use so much fertilizer and the
other is of course energy directly a
farming is an energy intensive business
you need energy to be able to run your
tractors and to be able to move the
crops around they're bulky and big you
may have prices going up very fast but
the cost of inputs are going up even
faster so even as food is running short
margins are low if this wasn't bad
enough there's one last thing to
consider which is that even before the
war started
the situation for global food supply was
looking pretty bad you had a bad weather
system la nina which affects uh both
latin america
and
and africa you've had
heat waves in india which could affect
the indian crop um and of course you had
kovid which was a big disrupt and this
comes on on top of it
and i think
you know we've spent so long talking
about this war as something that's sort
of affecting ukraine and europe and
that's rightly so but through this it
could affect hundreds of millions of the
world's most vulnerable people and all
across the world i just want to turn
within the last few minutes to a topic
which is a big topic nato membership of
sweden and finland and the consequences
thereof
shashank how does this change nato i
think it's strengthened nato this is you
know finland has the biggest artillery
force in europe this is a highly capable
armed force um that knows how to defend
itself so it's very well prepared these
aren't liabilities
i've heard some officials say that these
forces nato finnish and swedish forces
are more capable of working alongside
nato and are more capable of working
alongside it than many existing members
of the alliance that's how deep that
relationship is
look at the geography of this to defend
the baltic states latvia lithuania
estonia having finland and sweden
integrated into war plans for the baltic
region which is a single strategic and
military space is a huge advantage to
nato um so for all those reasons i think
we're looking at a really strengthened
nato um
in a way that's going to be a boon to
the alliance in the coming years
from your perspective how do you think
putin will respond to nato expansion to
include sweden and finland he thinks
that this is a good thing for him
because it it sort of reinforces his
whole argument about russia's
encirclement the whole world is against
russia uh he wants actually
nato to be there because that is indeed
what gives uh credence to everything uh
he is saying and i agree with shashank
that we are
in a going to to see a completely
different nature these are two very
strong countries
economically um you know rich countries
joining the nato um
but for putin for internal purposes i
think he will he'll exploit it uh and uh
he doesn't i think he understands that
nato is not going to attack him and he i
don't think he's not going to risk
attacking nato
i think that the u.s dynamics in this
are absolutely fascinating i mean you
started off with the americans thinking
that
um this would all be over in you know
two or three days
and and then gradually you've had this
this realization that this war could
could mean something culminating in this
um incredible package 33 billion dollars
to start with which then congress bid up
to 40 billion
and which should get through the senate
um you know at some at some point
but then there's a kind of um uh
whiplash because if indeed this war
starts to drag into 2023 and through
into 2024 when you have the presidential
campaign and if donald trump is one of
the candidates for that
i think that that gives a sense that
there's a you know there's a a stopwatch
running on this something very profound
could change in the united states
approach to this whole conflict and that
will have a big effect in europe as well
because the europeans will be very
worried about being left carrying this
thing if the americans start to back
down so um you know i i hope we will be
doing these webinars sometime towards
the end of 20 20 23 but if we will i
think that's what we'll be talking about
i'm sasha nyauta executive editor at the
economist
this was part of a digital event
produced exclusively for subscribers to
the economist if you'd like to watch the
full recording of this or any of our
other events please click the link
you'll have to register first or you can
subscribe to the economist and enjoy all
of our journalism thanks for watching
[Music]